well my skates are sharpened the
henderson silver knights
now have a place to sharpen their own
skills on the ice the new minor league
hockey team in henderson of course
it is lifeguard arena opened its doors
this morning the ring is going to be the
team's practice facility and then host
other community programs as well
kevin martin is live practicing her own
hockey skills with a look at today's
festivities looks pretty nice in there
kevin
well no john actually i'm not practicing
my own hockey stills but yes a big day
here in henderson
lifeguard arena officially opening the
practice facility of the henderson
silver knights and
i actually have a pretty important
silver knight on hand he's going to
skate up
this was not rehearsed actually this was
all ad lib that was beautiful oscar
thanks for doing that and
your first time here at lifeguard arena
your initial thoughts of this place
i think it's amazing it's definitely a
first class facility and
in good vegas fashion you mentioned
first class i mean
expected from the vegas golden knights
organization right they do everything
right i got a little tour of this place
it's beautiful everything they have
everything i agree yeah
literally everything um they've treated
us players
uh you know like like i said first class
from the day one
and it shows now too with this new
facility and
this new t and then these new nice
jerseys so uh
i'm just really excited to start you
know being around here more often
and you mentioned the new jerseys um is
this your first time putting them on i
mean they're flashy they have the flash
of the golden knights of course but
there's some sophistication and then
it also there's some resemblance to the
golden knights jerseys
definitely i think that's cool i think
it's good to have that
kind of similarity and i do enjoy all
the details
just like the golden knights have so
also a little logo here
speaking of which so no i'm just really
excited to wear this with all my gear
and stuff
and oscar you've been here since day one
what is it like to be a part of
something i mean five
four five years ago hockey in vegas
everyone laughed now it's turned into
this hotbed
and here we are in the brand new
lifeguard arena for the ahl
affiliate of the golden knights what is
it like to see it from the ground up and
really this city just fall in love with
the sport of hockey fall in love with
the vegas golden knights and soon
the silver knights right no you said it
i mean
from day one it's been crazy it really
has been
uh the fans have been amazing uh
everything has just been great and
like you said i mean i just feel really
fortunate to be a part of this whole
journey
and now once again be a part of this
new journey with the henderson so i just
feel really great and i'm really happy
and fortunate to
be here awesome thank you so much oscar
of course like i said the brand new
opening of
life garnerita here in henderson we'll
be right back after this break